The system is rigged against you.
Okay,
you're going to die.
You're going to be ill like it's rough,
man.
Now you don't want to lay that at the
feet of the social structure because the
social structure,
at least in part,
is trying to have you not die,
right?
I mean,
that's why we have walls and electricity
and all of that and works pretty damn
well.
You know you're probably going to live
till you're 80 and the only reason
you're not going to live longer is
because we can't figure out how to get
you to live longer.
That's why you're not going to starve to
death.
Wild animals aren't gonna tear you in
pieces.
Tyrants aren't going to rip you from
limb to limb.
It's like these are good things.
Now you still got a big problem because
the cosmic system is rigged against you
in a sense,
but okay,
so fine.
What do you mean by that?
The off,
you know you're vulnerable and,
and,
and you can be broken and you will be in
many ways,
but you can't blame someone for that.
It's just,
that's the structure of reality.
Okay,
so what do you do about that?
Well,
as far as I can tell,
and I've always looked as a psychologist
for optimistic ideas and and I'm not,
it's not.
I'm not an easy sell with regards to
optimistic ideas,
especially because of my basic belief in
the idea that,
you know,
the most profound truth is that life is
suffering.
So okay,
fine.
Life is suffering.
You can't blame that on anyone.
All right,
so what do you do about it?
Well,
maybe nothing,
maybe nothing.
Maybe the jigs up,
it's hopeless,
you know,
but maybe that's not right.
Maybe here's something.
What do you have against the suffering
and the malevolence.
Let's say you have possibility.
You have potential in front of you,
inside of you even whatever that means.
So here's the question,
what would your life be like if you made
use of all the potential that you were
offered?
That's the optimistic question because
you can test it out.
Say,
okay,
well I'll just try that for a year.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna.
Do the best I can at everything that
offers itself to me just as an
experiment and then I'm going to see,
well,
is my life better or as my life worse?
It's like you try it for a year.
You think,
Huh?
So actually better.
My friendships are better.
My family's better.
I'm,
I'm less anxious.
I'm more positively oriented.
I'm less resentful and bitter and
jealous and angry,
you know?
I'm more physically healthy.
It's like,
Hey,
great,
and you still,
you're not that good at it.
So what happens if you did that for five
years?
That's a good addiction.
It's an addiction.
It's an addiction to possibility.
And then it's also an exponential thing.
And this is actually technically true.
We know this beyond a shadow of the
doubt.
There's this principle that economists
talk about.
They often call it the matthew
principle,
which is based on a statement in the new
testament from those who have
everything.
No.
Yeah.
Uh,
to those who have everything more will
be given.
And from those who have nothing,
everything will be taken.
It's really a vicious statement.
But what it means is as you go downhill,
you go downhill faster and faster,
and people know that.
It's like it isn't linear,
man.
It's exponential.
You do one thing stupid.
Then two stupid things happen.
Then for stupid things happen and as you
know before you know it,
you're done.
But the reverse of that is also true.
You do one good thing and then you get
to opportunities and you fix them up and
you get four,
and this is how the world works.
It's a fundamental economic principle
and you see because of that,
that a small proportion of people have,
most of the gains accrue to them and
they're the ones they're healthy.
That's luck often,
you know,
they didn't get run over by a bus,
like there's lots of arbitrary things
about life that have to go right.
But after that,
it's like those are also people who are
capitalizing on what they're being
offered without bitterness or
resentment.
And then maybe it won't work for you,
but you don't have a better.
You don't have a better plan in that.